when you think of venom you usually
think of the symbiote's main squeeze
eddie brock but another character from
venom lore is making waves in movies now
let's peel back the untold truth of she
venom from her dark origins and comic
books to her life on the silver screen
anne wang debuted in 1993's the amazing
spider-man number 375 a lawyer once
married to eddie brock and is approached
by spider-man to help track down her
ex-husband who's kidnapped peter
parker's seemingly resurrected parents
with anne's help spider-man manages to
trace venom to an old haunt of eddies
the thrill world amusement park and
secretly tags along and tries to appeal
the venom's sense of reason but she's
interrupted when eddie is attacked by
silver sable's wild pack while venom and
spider-man fights the pact together anne
helps peter's parents who turn out to be
robots built by the fiendish chameleon
escape she then returns to rescue eddie
from being killed things take a dire
turn when a damaged ferris wheel almost
falls on anne but venom with
spider-man's help manages to rescue her
in time she proceeds to point out that
spider-man wouldn't have tried to rescue
her if he were a bad person which
finally convinces venom to stop
terrorizing his longtime foe for a while
anyway
ann wang next appears in the 1995
miniseries venom's sinner takes all in
this story she gets shot by a new
version of the villainous sin eater anne
ends up hospitalized but is soon whisked
away by venom when the sin-eater tracks
her down to finish the job the trip to
venom's underground hideout reopens and
stitched up wounds which leads eddie to
try healing her by sharing his symbiote
when that isn't enough eddie tells the
alien suit to separate from him for the
time being so it can bond with anne
completely thus she venom is born as she
venom anne manages to save eddie from
two criminals who find his lair she does
this by violently killing them however
prompting a horrified eddie to blackmail
the alien into releasing anne and
merging with him again by that point
anne is fully healed but she's horrified
by her actions as she venom especially
once eddie reveals that the symbiote
can't actually force a person to act
against their will disgusted by both the
symbiote and what it's revealed about
herself and shuns eddie for making the
alien suit bond with her in the first
place despite this in the series final
issue anne briefly becomes she venom
once again to rescue eddie from a sticky
situation
despite her mixed feelings toward her
ex-husband and his symbiote friend ann
wang isn't interested in getting eddie
brock arrested unfortunately she still
ends up being forced to cooperate with
the police when they attempt to capture
her ex in 1996's venom along came a
spider and gives eddie a subtle heads up
when he tries to call her leading
eddie's symbiote to travel through her
phone receiver and temporarily turn anne
into she-venom once again this time
however the symbiote remains partially
attached to eddie leading to a euphoric
experience in which eddie and ann
experience each other's memories venom
rescues anne from police headquarters
but she is eventually arrested for
acting as his accomplice teddy's
symbiote travels to anne by telephone
once more this time bonding with her
fully she venom proceeds to go to thrill
world in the hopes of meeting eddie but
she finds it's become a hideout for
crime boss ld50 and his associates a
showdown between she venom ben reilly's
spider-man the police and ld50s gang
breaks out during which anne gives eddie
the symbiote to heal him from injuries
but not before getting her fair share of
punches and kicks not to mention green
slobber inn as she venom after ld50's
defeat eddie admits he still loves anne
who states she'd only consider letting
him back into her life if he put his
hatred for spider-man and reliance on
symbiotes behind him
since her debut anne wang has always
made it clear that she cares about eddie
even if they're on the outs the details
of how and when they broke up however
seemed to vary from comic to comic
1997's uncanny origins number 7 suggests
that eddie's narcissism is what ended
their marriage and that they broke up
before eddie was fired from the daily
globe newspaper for mistaking an
imposter for the sin eater it also makes
minor changes to how venom was reformed
having him and spider-man save anne from
a falling wall in the city rather than a
ferris wheel at a theme park 2008's
venom dark origin suggests things
happened even more differently it
depicts anne and eddie as still being
married when his inaccurate story about
the sin-eater was published it also
implies that it was eddie's obsession
with success that drove a wedge between
him and anne eventually leading to their
divorce eddie's constant blaming of
spider-man for his problems including
his firing didn't help either
ann wang has always liked being
she-venom a little too much and that
terrifies her by the time her story
reaches 1999's amazing spider-man number
19 anne has become afraid to even leave
her home in case the symbiote appears
and tries to bond with her once more a
poorly timed visit from eddie brock who
wants to get back together with her so
he can regain some sense of normalcy
makes things even worse and panic flares
to further heights when she sees
spider-man swing by her apartment window
in his black costume yet what truly ends
up being the last straw for anne is
seeing eddie transform into venom to
pursue the wall crawler this makes anne
realize that the symbiote isn't with
spider-man despite his all-black look
it's right in front of her after venom
leaves and mortified by the whole
experience leaps from her apartment to
her death when venom returns and sees
what's happened he swears revenge
thinking anne's earlier glimpse of
spider-man is to blame
though ann wang has passed away her
legacy lives on in a sun with eddie
brock's dna that the symbiote
impregnated her with during one of her
stints as she-venom
are you serious believing she won't be
able to raise the child due to her
growing paranoia over the symbiote and
forces herself to leave her apartment
and give the baby to her father-in-law
carl brock in 2019's venom number 12.
though anne vows she'll return for her
son she dies before she can make good on
her promise leading carl to raise him as
his own neither ann nor carl tells eddie
about the boy eddie doesn't manage to
meet him until he arrives wounded and
mind-controlled by the venom symbiote at
his father's home dylan and eddie are
initially completely ignorant of their
true connection nor are they aware that
anne unknowingly transferred the piece
of the venom symbiote still in her genes
to dylan granting him unique powers
eventually however they learn the truth
and eddie begins taking care of his long
lost son
ann wang and eddie brock are two very
different people yet for some reason the
venom symbiote seems to like merging
with anne almost as much as it likes
bonding with eddie brock an answer of
sorts to this confounding riddle is
finally given in 2020's venom the end
which asserts that ann wang is one of
the universe's most suitable beings for
bonding with the symbiote outside of
eddie brock not only that her
compatibility is right on par with that
of telcar a warrior from the cree empire
who served as the venom symbiote's first
host long before the alien suit ever met
ann wang or eddie brock unlike telkar
however who had to rely on scientific
enhancement to bond with the symbiote
and's high compatibility level is
completely natural it's never exactly
explained why anne meshes so well with
the symbiote although it might be
because as venom sinner takes all shows
she can be just as bloodthirsty as eddie
when pushed
in one alternate reality ann wang
becomes she-venom under very different
circumstances as detailed in 2020's
venom issues number 27 and number 28
this anne is the one who bonds with
venom in a dark cathedral rather than
eddie brock who is already dead in this
universe what's more she-venom
eventually transforms into agent venom
the identity spider-man's long-time
friend and ex-bully flash thompson
assumes in the main marvel universe not
long after anne becomes agent venom her
suit produces several other symbiotes
this is possibly to prepare for this
earth's conquest by codex a corrupted
version of anne's son dylan and his
symbiote armada this version of anne
meets the main marvel universe versions
of eddie and dylan brock when they're
accidentally teleported into her
universe the three team up with anne's
underground group of symbiote-resistant
soldiers to defeat codex and free the
earth
ann wang also makes an appearance in
marvel comics earth 3-1-1 continuity in
which all of the marvel superheroes are
active in the year 1602 she shows up in
the second issue of 1602 witch hunter
angela as the bride-to-be of one edwin
brock unfortunately this version of wang
isn't marrying brock for his personality
but because brock has used the
enchantress's magical elixir to
hypnotize her luckily witch hunter
angela and sarah ann shorten save wang
from marrying brock who soon loses his
head to angela's sword when he tries
fighting her and sarah as a red
four-legged creature that unsurprisingly
looks kind of like venom
it's hard to say to what extent venom
dark origin is canon to the marvel
universe as it doesn't always 100 square
with past events if the parts that don't
contradict anything are in continuity
though then ann wang and eddie brock
both went to a very famous college in
marvel lore empire state university
though it only exists in the comics
unlike the very real sunni empire state
college in saratoga springs new york
with which it's sometimes confused esu
counts many famed marvel characters
among its alumni and faculty luminaries
including norman osborne the human torch
kurt connors and emma frost have all
walked its hallowed halls at one point
or another the character most associated
with empire state university however is
peter parker aka spider-man though ann
wang is never shown meeting peter at esu
she does meet eddie there in venom dark
origin she starts a relationship with
him sometime after eddie takes credit
for stopping a gang who attacked them
both on the street who really rescued
ann wang and eddie brock you might ask
why none other than spider-man of course
venom has appeared in all kinds of
spider-man adaptations over the years
including multiple cartoons and three
live-action movies yet somehow she venom
who has a strong connection to eddie
brock and his symbiote hadn't appeared
in any spider-man movies or television
series until 2018's venom admittedly she
came somewhat close in 2012's the
amazing spider-man as ann wang is said
to be kurt connor's lawyer but she's
never shown thankfully the live-action
venom movie corrects that oversight with
style i just spit that guy's head off
overall ann wang isn't changed too much
in her on-screen debut she practices law
and has a romantic history with eddie
unlike the comics however the two break
up before they have the chance to marry
as eddie's snooping as a journalist
unintentionally torpedoes anne's legal
career when the venom symbiote possesses
eddie and becomes one of his staunchest
allies even becoming she venom to save
eddie's life the two share a kiss while
anne is she venom though they don't
fully rekindle their relationship as she
has moved on and is dating dr dan lewis
instead ann and eddie's paths cross
again and venom let there be carnage
however as any venom fan might have
guessed they would these two can't
escape each other that easily oh that's
[ __ ]
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book heroes and
villains are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one